[Music]
prince william just scored a new piece
of property and it's worth over a
billion dollars yeah that's billion with
a b
when his father became king charles iii
he became an even wealthier man
overnight
while much of the royal family's wealth
is kept in secrecy experts have been
able to piece together just how much
each member is worth and with the
changing of royal titles and transitions
of assets after queen elizabeth's death
looks like william who's now first in
line to the throne is inheriting the
private duchy of cornwall estate from
his father king charles iii
but that's not the only new thing in
william's life he's also gained two new
titles
william and catherine the duke and
duchess of cambridge and the duke and
duchess of cornwall as they became upon
the queen's death and charles becoming
king are now also to be known as the
prince of wales and the princess of
wales this was not automatic it was upon
the wishes of king charles
today
i am proud to create him prince of wales
to whistle comrade
the country
whose title i've been so greatly
privileged to bear
as my heir
william
now succeeds me as duke of cornwall and
takes on the responsibilities
for the duchy of cornwall which i have
undertaken for more than five decades
and now that the estate's been passed
from charles to william we're taking a
closer look the property built in 1337
by king edward iii is said to be worth 1
billion uk pounds equating to a whopping
1.2 billion u.s dollars
located in southwest england it consists
of a generous portion of land almost 140
000 acres and revenue from the estate is
used to fund the duke's public private
and charitable activities 25 million
dollars to be precise that's the income
or what charles's estate the duchy of
cornwall is worth now when charles was
in charge of that estate he voluntarily
chose to pay income tax and we're
expecting william to do exactly the same
what does it mean well essentially that
william is no longer reliant on the bank
of dad he is now financially independent
for himself kate their public
engagements and of course their children
meanwhile remembrances are well underway
for the late queen who died last week at
96. the queen approved all the plans for
her service with charles in advance
her majesty's coffin is being led
through a procession traveling to
significant royal locations
[Music]
the state funeral service will take
place at westminster abbey on monday
while this of course will be a very
difficult moment for the royal family
intensely private and emotional there is
every hope that it will also be an
opportunity for william and harry to
reconcile it was after all her majesty's
dying wish